whammo whammo right between the legs
[Music]
stay hydrated drink plenty of water or a
beverage of your choice I would not
recommend coffee I say too much caffeine
these are gonna be tense times anyway
you want to stay within yourself so
water fresh fresh water we can make it
sparkly water too but water plenty water
this is a time to reach out and use your
resources and faculties if that's the
word I'm looking for to to contribute to
the general good in the community of us
earthlings
number three number three music music
let music be a salve Anna tonic for your
system and share music sing songs
amongst ourselves oh I like this song
for all we know we may never meet again
before you go make this moment sweet
again we won't say goodnight until the
last minute I'll hold out my hand and my
heart will be in it here's a good one
here's a good one you know punches are
good they look good in the movies but
I'll tell you something good
the this the palm the the this part of
your of your heel palm heel poem you
just go like this and if an alien comes
up to you you know oh sorry mr. alien
here's a good show it seems as though
you're submitting and then BAM out of
nowhere
oh what's that mr. alien BAM and then
right here and you go up the median
lines so if you catch him on the chin or
you catch him on the point of the nose
you know ramming his nose right up into
his brain and not bad you could do some
damage
so he'll palm heel palm that's my that's
the and of course and my last one here's
another martial arts tip there's a move
called monkey snatches peach
if an alien has you from behind
blammo wham-o right between the legs now
I don't know what those aliens what the
anatomy is exactly but it's got to be
something Valle nura beware monkey
snatches peaches and you know you may
get a may get a little advantage Jeff
Goldblum signing off this is the lad
Bible those are my tips
you
[Music]